bienvenue à tous sur les chaînes
parlementaires c'est l'ère de parlement
hebdo fait le tour de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire bonjour
marion il mange un week-end et dans
l'actualité cette semaine le parlement a
voté pour la poursuite de l'opération
100 garris en centrafrique les
interrogations sont nombreux surtout à
droite le premier ministre connaît des
difficultés sur le terrain françois
hollande s'est rendu sur place en fin de
semaine
en pleine campagne pour les municipales
les membres du gouvernement les
principaux leaders politiques se sont
pressés au salon de l'agriculture ils
viennent pour parler agriculture certes
mais aussi pour y mesurer leur
popularité
comme chaque semaine le plus de l'hebdo
vous fait découvrir un documentaire
l'expérience l'horreur en salles cette
semaine l'histoire du leader politique
christoph blocher le plus haï le plus
admiré de suisse c'est aussi l'histoire
d'un face-à-face étrange singulier entre
un réalisateur et un homme de pouvoir
et nicolas dupont aignan 1 bonjour
bonjour vous avez été membre du rpr puis
à du rpf de l'ump qui vous avez quitté
en 2007 pour créer votre propre parti
debout la république alors vous êtes
maire d'yerres dans l'essonne est député
depuis
1997 en tant qu non inscrits alors c'est
une tradition dans cette émission des
coûts de votre portrait par vos
collègues justement députés
un peu décalé
quand je dis décalé c'est avec toujours
des idées qui sont à cheval entre la
nostalgie le populisme et un côté très
réac par moments c'est un gaulliste qui
s'égare
parce que nicolas est un ami que je
connais bien puisqu'il a partagé les
mêmes combats que moi dans le mouvement
gaulliste mais ces gars les combats qui
mène aujourd'hui tout on va qui est à
l'extérieur de sa famille je le regrette
je pense que c'est quelqu'un
finalement d'assez courageux parce que
il a pris le risque de quitter l'ump
pour fonder son propre parti il est
cohérent avec ses conviction même si je
ne les partage pas par contre je trouve
qu'il a une vision souverainiste d'un
autre temps à mon avis c'est un ovni
parce que d'abord il représente un
courant politique à lui tout seul son
petit parti n'a que lui comme
représentant il était dans le précédent
mandat positionné avec vu tous les gens
d'extrême droite là il est plutôt
positionné avec les gens du centre parce
qu'ils les non-inscrits donc je pense
que voilà on sait pas trop
finalement qu'est ce qu'il représente
vraiment dans le débat politique de
l'assemblée finalement vous apparaissez
comme quelqu'un d'assez inclassable est
ce que ça vous convient oui parce que je
ne considère pas que tous ces
personnages que l'on a vue qui au
demeurant sur le plan personnel sont
sans doute très sympathique
mène la france dans la bonne direction
et j'ai le sentiment que les français
partagent mon point de vue un secteur
aussi avoir tant mieux le portrait un
peu seul contre tous non je vous savez
il ya déjà un million de français qui
ont voté pour moi donc je me sens pas si
simple que ça il ya en 2005
55% des français télé majorité qui
avaient voté non la direction que le
pays prend depuis des années on voit le
résultat aujourd'hui en terme de chômage
d'insécurité dont vous savez j'ai
peut-être raison avant les autres et je
crois vraiment
que nous avons besoin en tout cas de
gens courageux dans la vie politique et
je pense que les français n'attendent
pas que moi mais d'autres et quant à la
solitude il ya beaucoup de personnalité
qui nous rejoignent il ya beaucoup
d'adhérents ce parti récent commence à
progresser on verra mais je ne me
considère pas du tout seul j'ai déjà
dotés de gaulliste qui fait gare
gaulliste quand même toujours celui qui
s'égare c'est le gaulliste qui signe
tous les traités qui met la france
soumise à des technocrates de bruxelles
ceux qui se sont égarés
ce sont justement ceux qui sont restés à
l'ump et qui ont travaillé la pensée
gaulliste peut-être notre semaine on va
dérouler tout le fil de l'actualité avec
une mise en garde du premier ministre
jean marc ayrault a tout d'abord crié
très fort contre les verts qui ont
soutenu les manifestations à notre dame
des landes et puis il a décidé de calmer
le jeu rim benameur au salon de
l'agriculture jean marc ayrault était
très attendu sur un sujet bien loin du
monde paysan celui de la présence des
verts au gouvernement ce week-end le
premier ministre avait rappelé à l'ordre
ses ministres du logement cécile duflot
après son soutien aux manifestations
anti notre dame des landes mais
désormais il préfère parler d'unité
président de la république a fixé un cap
qu'elle a mise en oeuvre du pacte de
responsabilité
avec tout gouvernement du travail toutes
les composantes de la majorité c'est ça
l'essentiel et on a besoin de tout le
monde toute chose qui va lui parler
le premier ministre se serait entretenu
tour à tour avec emmanuelle cosse puis
cécile duflot dont les deux camps le mot
d'ordre est le même
calmer le jeu le premier ministre a
demandé de sortir d'ambiguïté
manifestement il y avait eu une
incompréhension
emmanuelle cosse notre secrétaire
national l'a eu au téléphone hier les
ambiguïtés s'il devait y en avoir son
lever maintenant essayons de travailler
pour l'opposition c'est un nouveau signe
de l'affaiblissement du gouvernement
il n'a plus le choix je considère que
les verts n'ont plus leur place au
gouvernement cette incohérence exaspère
tout le monde et rool l'action
gouvernementale illisible nous avons un
premier ministre qui aujourd'hui est
terriblement affaibli n'a plus aucune
crédibilité
j'ai envie de dire c'est soit les verts
soit jean marc ayrault mais il faut que
ce soit tranché très vite maintenant une
décision qui pourrait intervenir après
les municipales
pour beaucoup ce scrutin pourrait signer
la fin des verts au gouvernement après
22 mois chaotiques
les écologistes utile musique de ce
gouvernement ou pas je vais vous dire je
regardais ces images avec vous et c'est
pathétique
vous êtes un petit peu désespéré j'ai
pas désespéré je suis comme tous les
français je trouve ça pathétique
ces jeux d'appareil on se croirait sous
une quatrième république désuète ces
écologistes qui prétendent avoir des
convictions et qui vont à la soupe
gouvernement il ironique totalement mais
les français sanctionneront tous la fin
ça ne mérite même pas qu'on en parle on
va reparler un tout petit peu si vous
deviez former un gouvernement demain
parce que oui il avait été candidat avec
sur présidentielle quelle place nous
laisseriez vous aux écologistes à mais
ce ne sont pas des écologistes à
l'écologie alors alors c'est différent
parce que le nom et le défi écologique
est un défi central du 21e siècle si on
n'a pas compris ça n'a rien compris et
c'est d'ailleurs souvent la droite ne
comprend pas et a laissé ce que je
regrette l'écologie par exemple non mais
le nucléaire il y aura une loi befeno
part de nucléaire on doit augmenter la
part belle à terme mais c'est évident
des énergies renouvelables mais pas des
énergies renouvelables telles qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui il faut une percée
scientifique il faudra une percée
scientifique sur le nucléaire
passée la quatrième génération il
faudrait une percée scientifique sur le
solaire le le pays le continent qui
inventera le panneaux solaires à haut
rendement énergétique gagnera la
bataille du 21e siècle donc c'est autre
chose que de savoir si on fume du
cannabis si on soutient héros
la droite a eu tort de laisser à cette
espèce de gauche libertaire nul
le monopole dans les collèges écologie
n'ont compris tous les discours
politiques bien sûr cependant je n'avais
ni bien sûr bien sûr parce que le monde
et est finie la planète les elle est
petite et on pourra pas ajouter toujours
plus de croissance sans la gérer
autrement chez les écologistes c'est
pourquoi j'ai toujours été pour cent les
verts sont pas quand les gestes sur des
arrivistes post soixante huitard l'école
vis de droite c'est possible mais
écologistes ni de droite ni de gauche
l'idée qu'on doit travailler autrement
et que la croissance de demain viendra
par une gestion intelligente des
ressources et puis pas par le tout
marché
il nous met une taxe carbone en france
délirante alors même qu'il est rentré
des produits dans notre pays en europe
qui vous sont produits par la pollution
ailleurs donc moi je suis pour une taxe
carbone aux frontières mais là ce sont
des écologies de pacotille
lundi l'assemblée a définitivement
adopté la proposition de loi dite
florange c'était une promesse de
françois hollande sur le site
d'arcelormittal est la loi oblige
désormais un entrepreneur a cherché un
repreneur pour un site rentable une loi
quelque peu édulcorée elle les
communistes ont préféré une nouvelle
fois s'abstenir tandis que l'ump a voté
contre le sénat avait lui par deux fois
rejeté le texte alors le ministre de
l'économie pierre moscovici parle d'un
compromis
responsable d'un signal pour marquer
qu'on ne peut pas fermer impunément un
site rentable mais moi j'étais favorable
à cette à cette loi j'ai toujours dit
j'ai visité pendant la campagne
présidentielle quantité de sites
rentables qui était fermée de manière
scandaleuse sans que par exemple des
cadres ou des ouvriers qui avaient un
beau projet puisse même le déposer c'est
à dire que m j'ai visité des entreprises
où les dirigeants les fermer notamment
lafarge dans l'yonne et ne voulait pas
la vente parce qu'en fait c'était une
entente et donc il fallait agir la loi
est un peu timorée mais moi je ne suis
pas sectaire édulcorer les trouve
édulcorer les communistes ont raison
mais c'est absolument indispensable
quand un groupe faire une entreprise que
s'il ya des salariés qui veulent
reprendre c'est l'esprit la
participation gaulliste et puissent le
faire on peut pas faire une entreprise
et interdire qu'elle soit reprise par
quelqu'un d'autre parce que ça c'est du
monopole privé et le libéralisme ordonné
s'est pas de laissez faire du monopole
privé est ce que ce texte
bas d'un peu de pair avec le pack de
responsabilités telles qu' on le
retrouvera aujourd'hui entre les
entreprises et l'état en panne de
responsabilité j'ai toujours pas ce que
c'est donc c'est un scandale parce qu'on
parlera du chômage mais d'abord
peut-être sur les entreprises mais les
entreprises on en reparlera sur le
chômage les entreprises elles ont besoin
d'avoir une monnaie moins cher des
charges moins élevées pour pouvoir
exporter et vivre donc alors on en
reparlera et si vous voulez bien on va
passer au mardi le parlement qui a voté
la poursuite de l'opération sogaris 7 en
centrafrique
ici du vote ne faisait pas vraiment
mystère par contre le débat était un
petit peu plus animé jean marc ayrault a
défendu la nécessité de la présence
française sur le terrain mais la droite
au chef des armées au président de la
république alors je vous propose
d'écouter le premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault et christian jacob c'est le
patron des débitants démarre cette
intervention
a permis d'éviter la destruction totale
de la centrafrique
l'action et le courage de nos soldats
force l'admiration les conditions sont
réunies pour qu'un accompagnement
international robuste militaire
humanitaire et politique permette à la
centrafrique de retrouver le chemin de
la paix d'ici là et nous revient de
continuer à assumer nos responsabilités
je le sais c'est un défi mais c'est
aussi l'honneur de la france oui ça va
vous choquer mais le président de la
république nous a menti en annonçant une
mission cour qui n'a pas vocation à
durer
nous étions partis pour six mois avec au
plus 1600 hommes votre ministre de la
défense admet du bout des lèvres que
cela sera plus long beaucoup plus long
vous nous emmener dans un piège terrible
terrible car la france ne peut plus
partir
sauf à prendre le risque insoutenable de
déclencher un génocide pour ce pays
alors le vote des parlementaires et la
situation centrafrique c'est notre zoom
de la semaine
bonjour automne glaser bonjour
journaliste écrivain spécialiste ô
combien spécialiste de l'afrique vous
avez entendu christian jacob oui c'est
un piège la centrafrique est ce que vous
en pensez oui c'est une forme de piège
dans le sens où la france ne pouvait pas
ne pas intervenir quand vous avez des
bases militaires comme la base à
n'djamena au tchad quelques centaines de
kilomètres dans centaine de km de bangui
la capitale de la centrafrique vous ne
pouvez pas ne pas intervenir en fait
c'est un peu l'histoire
africaine jédir de de la france et c'est
vrai qu'on voit bien et d'un côté la
france a pas du tout les moyens qu'elle
avait dans son ancien empire et son
ancien pré carré on voit surtout que ses
grands partenaires internationaux on a
l'impression d'une sorte d'anachronisme
historique ses grands partenaires là les
sols dans son ancien pré carré c'est
complètement scandaleux de voir par
exemple que le lien est à 1,5006
millions de deux soldats de toutes les
28 pays européens et finalement il en
envoie à peine et ils sont même pas
encore sur place n'a pas être 500
maintenant on parle de 1000 il faut voir
aussi qu'elle quelles troupes seront
vraiment envoyer et donc c'est vrai que
convenable bien pris d'ailleurs si le
président françois landry ce pays
retourne en centrafrique c'est bien pour
expliquer aux militaires français qu' il
ya quand même un objectif au nicolas
dupont aignan sociales shs tenue
pour la simple raison que j'étais pour
l'intervention parce que même si on peut
la critiquer il ya un moment dans la vie
il faut choisir sauf à faire de la
démagogie politique comme certains
mais je me suis abstenu parce que je
veux mettre l'accent j'ai voulu mettre
l'accent sur la faiblesse de la loi de
programmation militaire on ne peut pas
d'un côté envoyer nos troupes au mali
j'étais favorable en centrafrique et au
même moment
préparer un second plan social des
armées qui aboutit à démanteler notre
outil de défense et donc j'ai voulu
montrer qu'il y avait une contradiction
gouvernement comme dans le précédent
d'ailleurs à vouloir jouer à la guerre
si je puis dire envoyer nos troupes
risqué leur peau et en même temps
affaiblir notre armée alors moi je suis
pour l'intervention mais je suis aussi
pour que la france garde un budget
militaire
non négligeable et bien évidemment qu'on
sollicite nos partenaires mais avec
beaucoup plus de fermeté parce qu'on n'a
pas à faire le boulot en afrique pour le
compte de l'allemagne de l'angleterre et
tous les autres sans qu'il y ait une
participation au moins financière
jusqu'à quand la france doit-elle rester
en centrafrique la présidente par
intérim catherine samba pandza a appelé
la france à rester jusqu'en 2015 les
élections présidentielles croire va dès
le départ moi j'ai toujours pensé
que ça
c'est bien sûr tous les fils et le mali
ils sont la france est encore peu
présente en côte d'ivoire après avoir
été très actif avec les ivoiriens il
faut savoir que les troupes françaises
quentin interviennent à s'affirmer une
façon autonome il ya deux difficultés en
centrafrique non seulement elles sont
pas assez nombreux c'est bien évident
pour une opération avec un pays qui est
grand comme la france et la belgique ça
c'est une première chose mais en même
temps ferait plutôt des crs par exemple
dans bangui plutôt que d'aider jeunes
militaires français qui sont confrontés
à une violence qu'elles y sont pas ils
sont pas habitués avec du matériel qui
ne correspond pas du tout à ce qui se
passe à la situation réelle et une
opération policière aujourd'hui puisqu
il s'agirait en fait ce pays et la
france est intervenue comme du temps des
années 70 une petite mutinerie de
l'armée centrafricaine on déploie 500
types dans la vie et ça calme le jeu
mais c'est pas comprendre que ce pays
est en déshérence depuis plus de 10 ans
est victime on parle plus de la guerre
du darfour mais des dizaines de milliers
de john jowitt qui sont au nord de la
centrafrique depuis des années qu'ils
sont descendus avec la collection de
l'ancien ex c'est l'écart est donc je
veux dire que sont pas centrafricain et
les opposants tchadiens c'est un pur
désir ans depuis dix ans c'est pas avec
ça c'est pas avec 1600 soldats vous
allez régler les problèmes vous pensez
que l'onu va intervenir aujourd'hui il
vient bien évidemment mais dans un
premier temps la france elle-même à dire
combien selon d'état africains voulaient
en dix ans n'a pas besoin des nations
unies mais on voit bien que tu opération
des nations unies si l'on six ou huit
mois c'est il faut une très grosse
opération il ya plus de 20000 type qui
sera mille soldats des guides et des
casques des nations unies qui sont dans
le kivu dans le sam kivu en république
démocratique du congo si l'info fauci
c'est impossible de rester comme ça mais
ce qu'est ce qui est dommage c'est que
beaucoup d'amateurisme et il fallait
intervenir de la part de du président
marc verly mans et il fallait intervenir
il a eu raison en revanche il faut que
l'on dise la vérité aux français on ne
peut pas laisser en afrique d etat
disparaître on ne peut pas laisser
l'afrique dans cette situation j'ai été
à la présidentielle le seul candidat par
les d'afrique non pas dans un sens
post-colonialiste pas du tout mais si on
n'a pas une vision stratégique en europe
en europe pas seulement la france de ce
qui se passe en afrique on pourra pas
gérer les dizaines d'années qui viennent
il faut donc aider à l'installation de
régime il faut aider à la mise en place
de forces africaines il faut être
relayée par le nu il faut il penser ce
qu'ils sont de qualité c'est un peu ce
qui se passe
je veux dire d'un coup voilà et puis
vous avez une force de ronde il a mis ce
cas des forces africaines vous avez
aussi mille soldats dont personne ne
parle jamais pourquoi parce que j'avais
lu 108 cents pigeons ninon pas ils n'ont
pas les y aider avion je dire ils n'ont
pas ils sont pas déjà ils sont pas
souvent coordonnées et ce y sont
sous-équipés ils ont pas habitués à
travailler entre eux 1853 des 800
congolais vous avez c'est d'abord ils
sont assez otero pis il ya un problème
de coordination il ya un problème de
commandement et un problème de non pas
le matériel nécessaire et que c'est vrai
que quand françois hollande dit on va
former 20 mille soldats africains par an
on se demande avec y avait quoi avec
quel financement et surtout une
évaluation il ya eu un truc ça plairait
campe renforcement des capacités de
maintien de la paix pourquoi n'y a pas
de bilan de ça puisque la france a
informé pendant des années les gens
série qu'est ce qui sait pas ce que je
veux dire parce que souvent j'entends
mes concitoyens dans la ville dire oui
qu'est ce qu'on fait là bas etc
si l'europe et la france ne gère pas
cette affaire c'est la chine qui le
gérera un autre jour et ça veut dire des
matières premières le savez une
déstabilisation portes de l'europe donc
c'est fondamental comme la stabilisation
se désintéresse pas de l'afrique par une
espèce de complexe de culpabilité liée à
la période coloniale cinq ans arrive à
la fin
vous a compté l'autre maître et tapha
relation si ray même que enfin en tant
que vient mon spécialiste de l'afrique
moi j'ai pas me prononcer politiquement
mais j'ai quand même regretter qu'à
cette occasion quand le parlement débat
de la centrafrique qu'on débatte pas
justement de la france en afrique
quelles sont ses intérêts stratégiques
et économiques à très long terme le
problème de l'afrique du nord je vais
les rives ce sont des voisins tous les
autres pays du monde considère que c'est
à l'afrique de faire le boulot et bien
au moins que ça soit clair qu'il ya des
troupes françaises mais au moins qu'ils
aient un retour pour au moins le
contribuable se disent pourquoi il ya
des militaires sur le terrain tu
regardes un tout petit peu plus lointain
glaser mali centrafrique et demain par
le dd déjà vous avez vu cette volonté
comme la france appuie les moyens déjà
une époque on aurait missiles dix mille
hommes là on ajoute 200 300 400 de plus
et sert à vue peau alors il va y avoir
des petits force aux tchadiens heureux
on essaye on essaye à partir d'un
certain nombre de soldats de deux héros
dispatcher mais il faut savoir dans quel
but pourquoi est ce que est ce qu'on est
ce que c'est un retour en arrière
qu'elle est quelle est la vraie
stratégie gérer mon c'est vrai qu'on
voit pas encore cap rémunération vous
êtes d'accord aussi débat il faudrait un
vrai débat sur la présence de la france
en afrique n'a pas encore eu lieu non
merci antoine glaser pour votre
éclairage sur la françafrique alors
mardi à l'assemblée justement juste
avant ce débat sur la françafrique les
questions au gouvernement ont été
l'occasion d'une attaque et de manuel
valls contre claude goasguen le ministre
de l'intérieur a attaqué le député ump
accusé d'avoir été membre d'un mouvement
d'extrême droite dans sa jeunesse en
réaction les députés ump ont quitté
l'hémicycle et demander des excuses jean
baptiste daoulas
l'opposition interroge manuel valls sur
les débordements du week-end à nantes la
question n'est pas posée par claude
goasguen mais c'est bien lui que le
ministre de l'intérieur interpelle farce
à cette extrême droite eh bien nous
répondons monsieur goasguen vous en
venez vous de l'extrême droite vous
savez ce qu'il en est nous nous tenons
complaisant avec personne
vous êtes complaisant et nous nous
créions et chaussons clair avec nous
l'opposition est indigne et l'ump décide
de quitter l'hémicycle pour dénoncer une
attaque personnelle pour protester le
groupe va boycotter les questions au
gouvernement c'est pour mettre un coup
d'arrêt à ce type d'attitude des
ministres qui ne répondent pas aux
questions et qui vont systématiquement
sur le domaine de l'insultent l'ump
demande des excuses mais le gouvernement
n'y ait pas disposer le ministre de
l'intérieur reste droit dans ses bottes
il faut que la droite soit responsable
la critique elle est logique mais il
faut pas utiliser tous les sujets pour
polémiquer de manière inutile contre
productive le gouvernement accuse l'ump
de dramatiser l'incident à quelques
semaines des élections municipales
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya là une
posture préélectorale qui probablement
expliquer davantage que la réalité de
l'incident pas de quoi apaiser l'ump
bien décidé à faire passer un message
nous voulons dire au gouvernement que
nous n'accepterons pas tout qu'il a
franchi des limites que l'insultent n'a
pas sa place dans l'hémicycle et qu'il
faut que le gouvernement se ressaisisse
mais le gouvernement va plus loin
sa porte-parole estimé ce matin que
c'est à l'ump de présenter des excuses
aux forces de l'ordre pour avoir remis
en cause leur travail à nantes et les
députés ump ont boycotté la séance des
questions au gouvernement mercredi
ont-ils raison nicolas dupont aignan
sans doute mais quelle cour de
maternelle enfin c'est quel spectacle au
moment où les français
souffrent du chômage baisse du pouvoir
d'achat de l'insécurité et monsieur
valse
des passes dépasse l'entendement et il
s'en prendre comme ça comme j'étais lors
des sommets il est pas capable de
rétablir l'ordre public dans notre pays
il n'est pas capable d'assurer l'ordre
public à nantes et donc ils sèment le
désordre à l'assemblée pour faire
oublier ses responsabilités
ces politiciens bien évidemment mais
qu'elle est toujours la même chose
le gouvernement
sent bien que les français se détournent
de lui sent bien qu'il est totalement
totalement inefficace et donc il n'a
plus que l'idée de complaisance à
l'égard de l'extrême droite voilà alors
il fait pas le ménage d'ailleurs sur
l'extrême gauche il laisse des casseurs
faire n'importe quoi à nantes et donc in
a que ce mot à la bouche et utiliser la
nama fermenté l'explorateur ce que vous
attendez mais c'est leur seule stratégie
pour se maintenir au pouvoir c'est leur
seul essai leur sol logiciels et je vais
vous dire les français vont sanctionner
ça très violemment parce que eux on ne
demande pas à des ministres d'insultés
de menaces et de dire ce qui doit peut
être dit ne peut pas l'est de la ville a
d'ailleurs l'interview de monsieur valls
après eux en gros c'est lui qui doit
décider ce qu'on a le droit de penser de
dire en france on n'a jamais vu un
ministre de l'intérieur on n'a jamais vu
un ministre de l'intérieur à ce point
vouloir faire la police de la pensée
alors même qu'il est même pas capable de
faire la police dans la rue justement la
chasse vers le bus a justement la
question du député ump à l'origine
c'était y at il une diffusait une
différence de traitement entre l'extrême
gauche et l'extrême droite c'est une
honte c'est une c'est gentil
complaisance pas complaisance il ne
nomme même pas l'extrême gauche et il
combat une extrême droite imaginaire et
ils ne nettoient même pas l'extrême
gauche réelle donc ça suffit et il faut
arrêter et il faut surtout surtout mais
j'aimerais leur dire mais
regardez ce qui se passe dans le pays
allez voir les chômeurs allaient voir
les les campagnes où les cambriolages
ont explosé allez voir les gendarmes qui
ont plus de moyens occupez vous de ça au
lieu de continuer ça cette façon de
parler partout manuel valls auront
peut-être des sondages partout pour
l'instant attendez de voir
éventuellement pour un poste de préfet
nous avons pour achat avec ça il a fait
ce qu'il est encore crédit poitrenaud
jour ce sera aux français de juger au
président de la république mais vous
salir bon courage bonne chance moi je ne
crois pas qu'un pays qui souffrent puis
se permettre l'invectivé et la division
je pense qu'on a besoin de rassemblement
il y en a de besoin de stratégies les
volontés de la division mais bien sûr
comme il est incapable de régler les
problèmes dont il est chargé ils
s'aiment l'a dit vision par la
provocation c'est pas digne d'un
ministre on a on en a connu les comme ça
dans le passé ça leur a pas réussi
nicolas dupont aignan tout à l'heure on
avait dit nous allons parler du chômage
mais c'est d'ailleurs c'était mercredi
18h les chiffres du chômage sont tombés
et encore une fois les chiffres du
chômage ne sont pas bons + 8900
demandeurs d'emploi supplémentaires au
mois de janvier alors on va écouter le
ministre du travail michel sapin il
était l'invité de questions d'info sur
lcp le chômage des jeunes a reculé en un
an il rejoindrait dans l'eau il a reculé
en allant de l'ordre de 20 mille jeunes
en moins je souhaite que 2014 soit pour
tous les chômeurs à l'image de ce que
nous avons fait en 2013 je souhaite
qu'en 2014 le chômage recule en france
voilà c'est encore une nouvelle promesse
de michel sapin comme françois hollande
fait si j'ai bien compris il souhaite
échoué en 2014 comme en 2013 c'est
honteux filtrer il a échoué et il nous
dit on veut la même chose non mais
attendez tout ça n'est pas sérieux
encore une fois alors que on pourrait
avoir des résultats sur le front du
chômage mais faut changer de politique
et moi je voudrais pas
la difficulté de la période présente
c'est que nos compatriotes sont
totalement désespéré parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment qu'on peut pas changer les
choses ils ont eu un gouvernement de
droite ils ont un gouvernement de gauche
c'est la même politique moi je veux leur
dire au contraire que sur le front du
chômage on pourrait avoir un million de
chômeurs en moins en cinq ans si on s'en
donnait les moyens de responsabilités
n'ont pas de responsabilité c'est quoi
ça peut pas fonctionner je vais vous
donner un seul chiffre un seul chiffre
le pack de responsabilité allez ça va
être une baisse de charge de quoi 5% 6%
oui bon au même moment monsieur cameron
l'angleterre
le premier ministre japonais le japon
ont baissé la valeur de leur monnaie de
20 à 30%
mais justement c'est le problème
je regardais les chiffres
regardez regardez les chiffres sur
internet depuis août 2012 je n'ai pas
amené là mais vous les retrouverez le
dollar australien -40% la roupie
indienne -37% de mémoire le dollar
canadien
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que tout les
pays du monde qui réussissent dans la
mondialisation
ceux qui réussissent jeu au début de
l'émission faisait passer là monsieur
leroux pour un dépasser un gars de
passéiste assez curieux les pays qui
font baisser le chômage dans le monde le
japon l'angleterre les états unis la
chine le brésil la corée du sud c'est
curieux ils dévaluer leur monnaie pour
gagner des parts de marché les écoutes
le problème c'est l'europe et l'euro
mais bien évidemment c'est vous discuter
des heures du pacte de responsabilité
entre nous écoutons travail mis en place
depuis 22 mois ah mais c'est
extraordinaire il est revenu depuis 22
mois mais vous allez garder quand vous
allez à b bien évidemment parce que vous
allez gagner mais pas d'espoir auprès de
toi mais aucun vous allez gagner 5 % de
baisse de charges 5% et au même moment
vos concurrents vos concurrents sont en
train d'utiliser la bombe atomique pour
conquérir des marchés je rencontrais un
exportateur là hier l'assemblée
nationale un projet je dirais pas le
pays d'un milliard 500 millions d'euros
par une grande entreprise française à
l'étranger
en compétition avec le japon il me
disait c'est foutu on est 200 millions
au dessus qu'uniquement la valeur de la
monnaie donc vous avez une europe qui
est prisonnière de l'euro marque de
madame merkel qui est un pays en suicide
démographique a pas d'enfant à nourrir
nous nous avons une jeunesse à nourrir
vous avez vu l'article dans le monde sur
les 200 milles john key était fait 61%
des jeunes veulent se révolter 46%
estiment qu'ils n'ont aucun espoir oui
me vont casser dans la rue parce qu'on
va avoir des violences au mois de mai si
ça continue parce qu'on peut pas
continuer à donner à notre jeunesse
comme seul espoir le taux de chômage
vous avez vu aussi que c'est l'épée
ohrid marine le pen également qu'il veut
aussi sortir une ruche événement et
beaucoup d'autres gens vous avez vu que
les français ne sont pour l'instant là
pour l'instant mais le rôle d'un homme
politique c'est quoi s'ils suivent les
sondages et de dire aux français c'est
le rôle d'un homme politique et c'est
mon rôle c'est de dire aux français
voilà si on veut résoudre nos problèmes
il faut sortir de l'euro au plus vite
sinon ce sont vos salaires qui vont
baisser de 20% et ça a commencé
regardez les entreprises ont fait
baisser les salaires façon n'y a pas
cinquante solutions soit vous avez une
dévaluation de la monnaie comme tous les
pays du monde son sauf l'allemagne soit
vous aurez la baisse des salaires la
récession l'austérité et les troubles
sociaux en france et là je le dis de
manière très grave il ya urgence à agir
a changé de politique et l'ump
d'ailleurs comme le ps en sont
incapables donc il faut proposer une
autre poutre poursuivre justement
nicolas les flandriens avec le salon de
l'agriculture c'est le rendez vous des
agriculteurs mais aussi et surtout un
passage obligé pour tous les hommes et
femmes politiques françois hollande
samedi jean marc ayrault lundi tout
comme jean françois copé et marine le
pen aussi mardi la présidente du front
national justement il en a profité pour
critiquer une fois de plus l'europe et
le traité et transatlantiques écoutez la
c'est un électorat qui est en train de
comprendre qu' il est le grand perdant
de la mondialisation sauvage de
l'ultralibéralisme des accords de libre
échange qui se multiplient et alors même
que la classe politique est dans
l'incapacité de répondre aux
préoccupations qui sont celles des
agriculteurs qui sont de plus en plus
nombreuse faut le dire le salon
l'agriculture est ce vraiment le bon
lieu pour parler d'europe parce qu'on
sait que les agriculteurs en france
vivent notamment des aides de la pac la
politique agricole commune des aides
européennes bien sûr moi j étais mardi
aussi comme tous les ans
bien sûr mais c'est pas le rock est des
agriculteurs l'europe c'est de l'argent
français puisque je vous rappelle que
nous donnons 7 milliards de plus que
nous recevons donc c'est l'argent
français qui part à bruxelles et qui
redescend mais moi je ne suis pas
hostile chez pas comme madame le pen là
dessus je pense qu'il faut garder une
politique européenne agricole en
revanche il faut eux remettre en place
une politique réguler et organiser et il
ya une décision très simple sur
l'agriculture je paye que l'on sait que
monsieur le maire comme sur le foll qui
sont en fait les petits télégraphistes
bruxelles ont accepté la suppression des
quotas laitiers la libéralisation du
prix du lait ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
nos éleveurs sont en très grande
difficulté sur les images vous étiez
également présents battait au salon de
l'agriculture vous étiez notamment les
gens viennent voir aussi sur ce qu'on
appelle un made in france oui
les spécificités très française le monde
agricole aujourd'hui c'est un monde en
crise selon vous c'est un nom de ya de
monde d'ailleurs agricole attend c'est
ce que nous avons également des elle
sera entendue sur place c'est quoi c'est
clair c'est que aujourd'hui l'élevage
est sacrifiée dans notre pays et que
l'on va devenir importateur de l'est que
la grande distribution
et l'industrie laitière sont en train
d'asphyxier nos éleveurs en payant le
lait à un prix inférieur au coût de
production donc ça peut pas durer j'ai
vu des gens désespérés vous avez un
suicide tous les deux jours
d'agriculteurs en france dans la
différence générale alors ils viennent
tous de parler au salon de l'agriculture
mais il ya des mesures à prendre s'il
n'y a pas de fatalité j'ai vu encore une
fois c'est ça qui est très dur pour
enfin tout cas pour moi et pour beaucoup
de responsables politiques c'est que
comme on a été mal gouverné par
différentes équipes les agriculteurs
j'ai vu me disant on y arrivera pu c'est
fini on va fermer eh bien non on peut
très bien pourquoi le canada pourquoi le
canada a réussi à protéger ces éleveurs
pourquoi la france et l'allemagne ont
réussi à le faire dans les années 80 et
pourquoi aujourd'hui nous responsables
c'est pour vous le malaise le problème
c'est l'europe bien sûr c est pourtant
ils disent et marion de la manière dont
l'europe et gérer parce que les
diffuseurs ne ment c'est complètement
différent colada oui c'est différent
mais j'ai toujours été clair je veux une
europe des nations libres et des projets
et jeudi que les gouvernements français
se sont écrasés coucher devant bruxelles
ils ont confié le pouvoir à des gens non
élus et y subissent cela il ya un moment
où la france doit dire stop ça va pas
dire se refermer ça veut dire contre et
c'est à partir de sortir de l'europe
certains besoins des clients sortir
l'union européenne de l'europe c'est
différent ce que je dis ça veut dire que
on pourra sauver l'europe si on se
débarrasse de l'union européenne telle
qu'elle fonctionne aujourd'hui et qu'on
recrée une europe des coopérations
c'est-à-dire d'alliance deux pays à
quatre ou cinq sur des sujets précis
dire que comme ça qu'on y arrivera c'est
pas contre l'europe c'est contre la
manière dont on dirige l'europe
aujourd'hui il nous reste encore
quelques petits les voies avoir pour
cette semaine de temps jeudi les
révélations du magazine le poids qui ont
l'effet d'une bombe sur la sphère copé
c'est le magazine de poids donc il
annonce à la une jean françois copé le
président de l'ump aurait-il profite et
fait profiter à ses proches de contrat
de communication entre autres sur les
fonds du parti on voit tout ça avec elsa
dac
le point l'a baptisée la sphère copé
selon l'hebdomadaire jean françois copé
aurait privilégié une agence de
communication lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 la société
bygmalion fondée par des proches du
président de l'ump 8 millions d'euros
auraient été payées à une fidèle de
cette entreprise pour différentes
prestations elle aurait été largement
surestimée comme ces 76 1523 euros
facturés pour un meeting dans une ville
de 17 mille habitants au cours de cette
enquête nous avons récupéré les factures
de la filiale événementielle
2000 mhz à lyon pendant la campagne et
nous avons soumis ses factures à un
certain nombre de spécialistes du
domaine le spécialiste de l'évènementiel
et qui ont détecté sur certains postes
d
pris le double des prix habituel et en
globalité des surcoûts de 20% jean
françois copé rejette les accusations du
point et porte plainte pour diffamation
c'est un coup monté totalement de
manière absolument ignobles et c'est
extrêmement grave statut sud mensonges
et tout cela donnera lieu évidemment à
une réponse devant les tribunaux il ya
derrière ça un homme prendre ce livre et
gilbert qui depuis des mois et des mois
nous attaquent nicolas sarkozy comme moi
même pour nous détruire bastien millot
cofondateur de bygmalion s'est exprimé
sur europe 1 radio où il assure une
chronique je pense qu'il ya eu peut-être
la volonté de taper ou de faire un scoop
qui a pris le pas sur la volonté d'être
peut-être un peu plus transparent un peu
plus on va dire méthodique toujours
selon le point ces dépenses en
communication rétais été supportés en
majorité par le parti et non par le
candidat sarkozy cinq des huit millions
d'euros en question c'est une question
presque traditionnelle mais à qui
profite le crime aujourd'hui c'est rien
moi je pense aux militants ump j'étais à
l'ump je sais qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de militants sincères et d'adhérents
d'ailleurs souvent avec un esprit
gaulliste et et je pense à eux parce que
savoir qui donne de l'argent et qu'après
cet argent est dépensé comme cela on
peut s'interroger dis pas que c'est
illégal ou légal ils feront leur ménage
du génocide ménage ensemble moi ce que
je retiens ce que j'ai fait une campagne
présidentielle avec un million d'euros
et que pendant ce temps là l'ump pour
des meetings uniquement dépensé 8
millions d'euros et des suspicions mais
pas avoir suspicion que que lui avec ses
problèmes c'est pas moi d'intervenir ce
que je veux et il y en a interdit tout
le monde savait mais mais moi je suis
pas l'ump depuis maintenant 2007 j'ai
quitté l'ump justement parce que je
n'aimais pas le mode de fonctionnement
de ce parti au delà des idées sur
l'europe j'ai un chemin plus difficile
on a mille fois moins d'argent mais au
moins dans nos convictions et j'invite
d'ailleurs les électeurs de l'ump aux
européennes a voté en fonction de leurs
convictions parce que je présenterai des
listes et et j'espère qu'ils verront la
différence encore à devenir lui même
plus aujourd'hui mais sûrement la
question le problème de l'ump c'est un
problème de fond on le voit sur les
européennes il est tiraillé entre une
vision par exemple fédéraliste centriste
et puis une vision plus nationale
souverainiste est vraiment j'appelle
pour les européennes les électeurs qui
pensent que moi ils peuvent rester à
l'ump mais à voter pour nos listes mais
non parce que c'est important ça j'ai
passé 20 heures c'est important non mais
on peut pas continuer avec ces deux
grands partis parti socialiste et ump
qui ont un fonctionnement très près à
nyc avec beaucoup d'argent public parce
que tout ça c'est l'argent public dans l
ump s comme marine le pen est un
problème de deux parties qui dirige et
si madame le pen est si haut c'est pas
par hasard et moi justement je me bats
pour qu'il ya patriotisme républicain
tranquille qui existe d'ailleurs je j'ai
été comblé parce que j'ai vu qu henri
guaino henri guaino a dit qu'ils
voteraient pas pour monsieur lamassoure
en ile de france où c'est un bon point
mais au-delà de ça henri guaino a dit ce
que je pense c'est qu'il faudrait
constituer un vrai parti gaulliste
patriotes apaisé sans les défauts du
front national mais sans
l'esprit qui règne aujourd'hui à l'ump
on entendu votre appelle donc à henri
guaino
cette semaine le plus de l'hebdo
s'intéresse aux portraits de christophe
l'horreur
christoph gloor heures c'est le leader
de la principale formation à politique
helvétique l'union démocratique du
centre jean stéphane bron l'a suivi en
2011 il en a fait un film le portrait du
plus grands leaders populistes et
nationalistes européens simon barbarie
voitures sillonnent la campagne
helvétique
un trajet sinueux à l'image du parcours
politique de son passage et christophe
que l'horreur l'un des plus grands
leaders populistes et nationalistes
européens le documentaire l'expérience
l'horreur de jean stéphane bron en
salles actuellement retrace
l'irrésistible ascension de ce fils de
pasteur devenu milliardaire et homme
politique de premier plan au point de
conquérir près d'un tiers de l'électorat
suisse
vous dites pour imposer un thème dans la
société il faut savoir élever le niveau
de provocation
inquiet au gouvernement un pied dans
l'opposition moitié homme d'état moity
chefs de partis ont joué la stratégie de
la tension
en moins de vingt ans son parti lui
décès l'union démocratique du centre a
réussi à imposer son europhobie et sa
xénophobie dans la société helvétique le
sa première victoire en 1992 avec le
refus de la suisse d'adhérer à l'espace
économique européen
le documentaire tourné en 2011 évoque
aussi de manière inattendue l'histoire
immédiate
le référendum du 9 février dernier
contre l'immigration de masse
cette voie
elle est chaude
devenir
les nombreux silences de christoph gloor
heure aux questions du documentariste
ajoutée aux effets de style de sa mise
en scène conduisent un portrait
psychologique du politicien le fond de
sa pensée politique est alors reléguée
au second plan original mais pas
forcément plus pertinents est ce que
vous vous reconnaissez dans les
positions européennes notamment de crise
christophe l'horreur pourquoi devrais-je
me reconnaître dans ses positions vous
savez moi je crois des frontières de la
suisse je crois que le monde tel qu'il
est gouvernée qui n'est plus gouverné en
fait par les hommes politiques que la
démocratie est en péril et quand on
n'est plus gouverné que c'est la jungle
et bien obligatoirement arrive des
leaders plus nationaliste et quand il
n'y a pas un patriotisme serein apaisé
et qu'on n'est pas bien gouverner et
bien obligatoirement arrive des excès
alors sur la suisse pour être clair que
la suisse veulent contrôler ses
frontières ça ne me choque former cette
décision il serait bien sûr bien sûr
parce que c'est pas la fermeture eux on
peut pas continuer moi j'habite en
banlieue les premiers d'ailleurs qui me
demande de contrôler les frontières ce
sont les enfants de l'immigration on
peut pas continuer à voir la jungle hier
j'étais dans une entreprise dans seine
maritime ils ont reçu un fax marqué
voulait embaucher des travailleurs
roumains polonais ça sera deux fois
moins cher c'est légal téléphonez-nous
eux on peut pas continuer comme ça en
suisse ce sont les frontaliers français
la monarchie mais non c'est pas du tout
ça en suisse ils demandent quoi
légitimement de contrôler les frontières
mais c'est très simple moi je vais vous
dire ce qui va se passer soit les
républicains c'est à dire les gens
apaisé raisonnable contrôler les
frontières développe l'économie offre du
boulot aux jeunes soit ce seront des
nationalistes plus dangereux ne
considérait pas comme nationaliste mais
comment pourrais-je devrait considérer
je suis patriote gaulliste je crois à la
république la démocratie n'existe qu'au
niveau national on en a la preuve
aujourd'hui on a créé un système sans
frontières qui est un système d'
esclavage de nivellement par le bas de
pauvreté de masse de misère d'absence de
choses de d'emplois pour les jeunes
c'est ça le résultat de tous les traités
signés par le ps l'ump les verts les
centristes au nom de la belle europe moi
j'aime l'europe mais j'aime vitalic
quand elle est italienne là pense quand
elle est française je veux une europe
des peuples libres et qu'ils travaillent
ensemble sur des projets ce que font
tous les pays du monde on interdit à la
france de faire ce que fait le maroc
israël la corée la malaisie etc on vit
hors du temps tout ça parce qu'une
petite classe pardonnez moi à paris qui
est internationaliste qui ne vit pas les
souffrances et le jour où claire chazal
sera remplacée par une roumaine payer
dix fois moins et j'attaque pas du tout
claire chazal tout d'un coup eux les
grands présentateurs et les grands
éditorialistes français découvriront ce
que c'est que l'europe moi je demande
simplement à ce qu'on ait un patriotisme
apaisées et que la france puisse se
développer comme se développe la corée
du sud où l'angleterre de monsieur
cameron et vous verrez que s'il n'y a
pas rapidement chez les républicains une
reprise en main des choses et bien ce
seront des gens plus sulfureux qui ne
correspondent pas à l'idée que je me
fais de la république qui viendront mais
de grâce ne confondez pas les patriotes
républicains comme moi avec ce qu'ils y
font excès voilà le message là aussi
encore une fois passé ce merci vous
passez ce que je suis nicolas du point
gaubert d'être venu dans notre émission
parlement hebdo la semaine prochaine on
change un petit peu le concept ont fait
à partir de la semaine prochaine une
spéciale élections municipales municipal
hebdo jusque fin mars avec les résultats
des élections municipales merci de nous
avoir suivis à la semaine prochaine